middle class Joe and his wife well they
love to portray themselves as living a
middle class lifestyle but it appears
that image was not quite accurate as Joe
was buying expensive Corvettes and again
that beachfront property and now let's
see what the bidens do are they ready to
throw their own son under the bus anyway
here with more with the very latest
house oversight committee chairman uh
James comr is with us uh good to see you
Senator so can you explain this whole
process you are a super my understanding
is of your subpoena you want a closed
door under oath deposition and you want
materials handed over is that correct
sir that's correct this is a normal
subpoena this is a normal Congressional
subpoena uh it's a lawful subpoena uh we
have asked him to come in on December
13th his attorney said today that he
would gladly come in uh but only for a
public hearing he'll have a public
hearing after we do the deposition this
is the way credible investigations are
conducted and Hunter Hunter Biden is not
above the law just because he's gotten
away with uh criminal activity by the
doj the FBI the IRS the National
Archives doesn't mean he's going to be
treated that way by the house oversight
committee we are going to abide by the
law Jamie raskins the the ranking member
on the house oversight committee did
this exact same process he had this a
very similar scenario with Steve Bannon
when he was subed by the January 6
committee he wanted to come in not for
deposition but for a public hearing
Raskin said he had to sit down for
deposition because that's what the law
requires that's what we require of
Hunter Biden we will gladly have a
public hearing with Hunter Biden after
we do the deposition to go over the
10,000 plus pages of bank records and
documents that we have with with
countless questions about specific
transactions do you do you need more
documents have you been requesting more
documents have they been forthcoming
with the information well the banks have
been very forthcoming the banks wanted
to give us this information look the
banks notified treasury for years of
criminal activity by the Biden family so
the banks the private banks have been
very Cooperative who hasn't been
Cooperative are the Biden uh is the
Biden Administration uh we've requested
all the the the pseudonym emails uh we
the number of emails that Joe Biden used
a fake name grows almost on a daily
basis we've asked for those emails
they've provided 14 pages uh there are
thousands more pages that they haven't
provided we need to know about that
because we know there was communication
between the White House between when Joe
Biden was vice president and Hunter
Biden and his associates even though Joe
Biden claimed numerous times on
television he had a wall between uh his
the government and his family Shady
business activities we know now that
there was no wall there that Joe Biden
used a fake eame to get around the foe
requirements so so normal invest
tigators couldn't find this out we've
worked very hard on this investigation
over the past eight months Sean as you
know we built a mountain of evidence now
we're in the deposition phase and that's
what the subpoena for Hunter Biden was
all about a deposition to sit down the
Democrats will get equal time and it is
for all practical purposes public we
will release the transcripts we will do
this the way every Congressional
deposition is been composed in history
and the American people will know
exactly how Hunter by answered these
questions in the deposition would he
have the right to plead the
fifth well I mean everyone has the right
to plead the fifth but you know
according to Hunter Biden's attorney
today he wants to come forward and I
think that's great give him an
opportunity he's going to have due
process he's going to be able to answer
some questions but this isn't about
Hunter Biden this is an investigation by
Congress of Joe Biden for potential
corruption Hunter Biden is a key witness
in our investigation of Joe Biden we
know the Biden family has received
millions and millions of dollars from
our enemies around the world we don't
know what they did to receive the money
we don't know a lot of things about how
the bidens have been able to afford such
lavish Lifestyles when we really don't
know what they do for a living other
than Hunter became an artist yeah he
became an artist when Joe Biden became
president well we do know that Hunter
admitted himself that he had no
experience in energy oil gas or Ukraine
uh but yet he was dealing with Ma and
his father took actions as as vice
president withheld a billion dollars
leveraged that billion dollars to get an
investigative prosecutor fired um and in
six hours the guy was gone the
investigation's over Hunter got paid and
this was 5 days after you have been able
to Chronicle a phone call that came from
Hunter from Dubai uh with barice
Executives is that correct sir that is
correct and we learned all that through
a transcribed interview
and that's what we want Hunter Biden to
do to come in for an interview everyone
knows that if you have a credible
substantive investigation you have
depositions you have transcribed
interviews then you bring in people for
committee hearings I'm not doing this
for entertainment this is a credible
investigation and we expect the
president's son to sit down along with
the other 19 people we've asked to come
in and answer questions the Democrats
will have equal time we will release the
transcripts this will be a very
transparent investigation as it has been
from the very beginning well the one
thing I've said to you Congressman a
number of times is Abby LOL is a real
lawyer one of the top DC lawyers for
sure uh let me ask you about a report
justnews.com editor-in Chief uh an
investigative reporter John Solomon that
he gave about Kevin Morris this friend
of this this friend of hunters and the
family out I guess in California and the
amount of money loaned is is that money
in the5 plus million doar range sir
that's what what we understand John
Solomon's done a great job uh
investigating this from day one we have
a lot of questions for Kevin Morris we
expect him to come in we've sent him a
letter we've asked him to come in uh
have you have you subpoenaed him sir no
you have to request uh through a letter
first we're doing this the the the right
way we're making sure every eyes dotted
and te's crossed if he doesn't respond
to our letter to come in voluntarily
then we will issue a subpoena we expect
to hear from Kevin course he's loaned
the president's son reportedly over $5
million he just met his president's son
uh during the presidential campaign uh
this raises serious campaign Finance
questions this raises serious ethics
questions and this raises a whole lot of
tax fraud
questions $5 million is a lot of money
if that all turns out to be accurate and
true and um uh did he do we have you
been able to discover or Trace maybe did
he get anything for that money is he
getting paid back for that money that's
a great question Sean that's what we
want to know and look the theme loan
continues to emerge remember the last
three payments that we found that were
uh traced to Joe Biden the two checks
from Jim Biden and Joe Biden that were
were written through the influence
pedaling scheme and a $250,000 wire from
China that was sent to Hunter Biden at
Joe Biden's home address all of those
the White House claims were loans loans
loans loans everything they say is loans
uh now we have Caravan Morris reportedly
loaning Hunter Biden over $5
million we have a lot of questions about
that and that raises a lot of tax
evasion questions it raises a lot of
Ethics questions and even campaign
Finance questions it would be
interesting to see if if any any I don't
know official government action was
taken for anybody that loans anyone
money um that would certainly raise a
lot of I
uh chairman comr We Appreciate You
updating us thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else